autre circonscription la onzième à
présent l'ex candidat à la
présidentielle benoît hamon ne sera pas
au second tour des législatives il a
annoncé lui-même qu'il était battu dans
cette circonscription il n'obtient que
22 61% des voix nadia république en
marche
arrive en tête suivi par jean michel
fourgous le maire d'elancourt qui a déjà
été député et qui avait été battu en
2012 par benoît hamon retour sur ce
premier tour de scrutin avec stéphane
servant sévère défaite hier soir pour
benoît hamon député sortant de la 11e
circonscription devant des militants
abattus rassemblés dans son fief de
trappes
il est venu leur annoncer qu'il eut
manqué plus d'une centaine de voix 165
exactement il n'obtient que 7400 36 voix
soit 22 59% des suffrages exprimés
une brève déclaration un mot de
réconfort aux uns et aux autres
même son ami maire de trappes étaient
sous le choc
une déception j'ai demandé jeudi comme
ça j'ai demandé à benoît pour les
élections législatives précédentes il ya
cinq ans de venir avec nous travailler
avec nous donc il avait été élu député
il était conseiller municipal
après il a eu du ministère etc non c'est
pas ça qui est important ici à trappes
il fait un excellent simple le vrai
montré de très devant devant devant mais
la circonscription est complexe et
composé de ville plutôt beaucoup plus à
droite que la ville de trappes et je
viens d'apprendre comme voulons que ça
passait pas pour le second tour quelques
voix près pas content il n'a pas pu
résister à la vague république en marche
qui a tout balayé dans le département
dans la 11e circonscription nadia et
obtient ainsi dit 1858 voix soit 32 98 %
des votes et arrive nettement en tête
devant le candidat
les républicains à l'image des résultats
des législatives de 2012 qui avait vu la
victoire de benoît hamon
dans le sillage de l'élection de
françois hollande la candidate en marche
profitent elles aussi pleinement des
résultats de la présidentielle
je suis satisfaite du résultat je vois
que les habitants de la circonscription
nous ont placés en tête
donc ils réitèrent leur confiance auprès
du président d' emmanuel macron et il
m'accorde aujourd'hui la leur
premier tour donc oui je suis contente
elle sera opposé au candidat des
républicains
jean michel fourgous maire d'elancourt
qui fut député avant de perdre son
mandat il est à 5 ans battu par benoît
comme tous les autres candidats
républicains du département ils
s'attendaient sûrement à récupérer ou
remporté son siège à l'assemblée avec
7600 une voix soit 23 de 0 9% des
votants
il résiste mais avec 10 points d'écart
il reste loin derrière il ne peut même
pas espérer exercer une force
d'opposition à l'assemblée qu'il faut
que les gens se soucient de l'equilibre
dimanche prochain si y'a pas un minimum
d'équilibré kepu de décembre les
nationales et plus de travail
d'assemblées nationales réelles c'est
que les technocrates qui ont pris tous
les pouvoirs ben là vous allez vous
élève à voir quand même des surprises on
pas de réunion publique prévue dans
l'entre-deux-tours jean michel fourgous
veut se concentrer sur un débat d'entre
deux tours qu'il espère avec nadia m
pour le reste des candidats mathurin les
vis de la france
insoumise recueil 8,65 % des voix et
mathilde andrew et pour le fn 7,03 % des
voix ces deux partis ne réussissons pas
à conserver leur score du premier tour
de la présidentielle un scrutin marqué
par un fort taux d'abstention dans les
yvelines
à peine mieux qu'au niveau national dans
la circonscription les abstentions ont
représenté 52 87 % des inscrits